hello everybody and welcome back to
learning with jagman x
that isn't actually a segment but i
guess it could be because i'm doing a
lot of tutorial videos lately and today
is no exception
i am going to show you how to make a
music video using a game engine unreal
engine 4 specifically so this video
actually follows on from my previous
tutorial which was how to write and
produce a song that detailed the behind
the scenes of a song called we feel it
too and today i'll be taking you behind
the scenes of how i made the music video
for that very song so if you have any
interest in music music production
song writing then please go and check
that video out there will be a link in
the description or it'll be
up here somewhere
i know
[Music]
so when i create a song that i feel is
worthy for release i often want to
release it with a music video why do you
need to do this you ask well simple
answer is you don't need to make a music
video however i really believe in
delivering the best narrative experience
that i can through my creations and if i
have the opportunity to
uh share with you both an auditory and a
visual experience then i will do that
because i believe that it enhances my
overall vision and creating a music
video in a game engine makes doing so
extremely accessible hence why i'd like
to make this video today to show you
that it is entirely possible to create a
music video of your own filming within a
games engine
i choose to create videos within a game
engine because it gives me more freedom
and opportunity to experiment with
different cameras different lenses
different locations
different lighting different times of
day even and this just simply isn't
possible if i were to film physically i
don't have the money to buy physical
cameras lenses lighting equipment and i
definitely do not have the time to take
out of my day job to go and scope
filming locations but with a game engine
you can take what you see in your head
and create it digitally without as many
restrictions you want to have a more
textured scene no worries let's just set
up an exponential fog and add some
particle systems you want a different
type of lens that's easy it's just in a
film back drop down menu for you to
choose from in the cine camera actor you
want to change the color grading of the
shop live well you can do that with post
processing those words might have just
gone right over your head but stick with
me here what i'm trying to say is that
everything that you would need to film
in the real world is easily readily
available for you within a game engine
i'm not trying to say it's better or
worse to film that way i'm just saying
that it's an option and i want to talk
you through how today so within this
video i will talk about creative
direction preparing art for a digital
environment developing the video within
unreal engine 4
and the final touches that i did in
premiere pro step one is creative
direction and the first thing that i
always start with is music video
narrative a video can help build upon
the narrative of a song providing
visuals that enhance the feelings and
meanings behind it when creating a music
video i always start by asking myself
how can this song benefit from a music
video and how can i best portray the
song's narrative during the production
process of the song i already had
established this narrative and theme so
i already knew the location that the
music video needed to be set in which
was a bedroom the music video needed to
fulfill the fantasy not the fantasy
the feeling of being in a bedroom during
lockdown which a lot of us were we can
relate to this the song is really
calming and has very chill vibes so i
knew i wanted to reflect that within the
music video and the first thing that
came to mind for me was a kind of lo-fi
art style an isometric bedroom and a
warm pastel color palette know your
limitations we can't be good at
everything and that is perfectly okay
and once we realize this we then know
that the sky is not the limit and we
won't be overwhelmed with possibilities
instead you can focus on what's
realistic for you
allowing yourself to focus on the skills
that you have instead of trying to reach
unattainable goals that will only
frustrate you so my own limitations and
workarounds for these limitations when i
was figuring out my music video were
limitation one i could not model and i
still can't model so my work around was
to work with concept artist braden may
who can model
and also to use a couple of models from
the unreal engine marketplace limitation
number two the concept artist had
limited time to work on this project
and 3d modeling was not their primary
strength so the workaround for this was
to work together to limit the amount and
complexity of the 3d models so that the
workload was manageable and attainable
for the concept artist limitation number
three is that i have no 3d animation
ability whatsoever so the workaround was
that i would have to look for an
alternative to bring movement to the
scene using my other skills which is
more of a tech designer more on that
later and limitation number four is that
i do have a tendency to strive for
perfection even though there's no such
thing so the workaround for this was
that i gave myself a soft deadline of
two months to complete this project uh
just so that i had a date to hold myself
accountable for
two four two four when i knew my
limitations and possible workarounds for
them i could then put together a plan
for the music video itself i decided to
have the music video focus on a really
simple bedroom having the camera pan
around it and showing elements of my
real room so it had a personal touch to
it and then with a more solid plan in
mind i could then create a list of what
i needed to bring that to fruition what
i needed was
one low potty 3d bedroom and
individual assets for that bedroom each
of these assets would have one material
per object and these would be created by
my lovely concept artist braden i also
made sure that the concept artist knew
that the walls and the objects of the
room needed to be their own separate
models so that i could hide or show them
to allow free movement of the camera
without having to worry about it
clipping through any of the environment
i needed low poly 3d assets from the
unreal engine marketplace to create a
city view from the bedroom window i
needed to have some sprite animations
created to add some movement into the
video and finally include elements of my
real bedroom as textures within the 3d
ones such as pages for my journal or
photos around my bedroom of me and my
friends
[Music]
documentation i know i know nobody wants
to document when they get to this stage
in the process they just want to get the
ball rolling that's the fun part right
but a solid piece of documentation is
vital to make a cohesive creation and to
stop you falling into the trap of
feature creep
because that can make you work on
something forever and then suddenly it
becomes something completely different
you don't want to fall into that hole
not all the time sometimes it can be
good but not all but not all the time
anyway this is beneficial for both the
cohesivity of the project and also your
own mental health and if you're working
with others it also just really helps to
clarify your vision to make sure that
everybody's on the same wavelength so my
documentation detailed the music video
narrative that i needed
the color palette that i would reference
when creating my materials the reference
images for the 3d models that had
inspired my vision a detailed list of
the 3d models and assets that i needed
from my concept artist links that would
be useful for me during the development
phase tutorials things like that and a
to-do list for the development process
so that i could take things off as i
went along and i knew that i wasn't
missing anything step two preparing art
for a digital environment
so 3d modelling this image is the
wonderful 3d room that concept artist
brayden may created for me in blender
thank you very much it's very cute very
good indeed these assets had a very low
poly count and also most of them had no
texture map which made the artist's job
much faster however it did mean that i
couldn't bake the lights as the texture
information was completely wrong on most
of the models and it made the shadows
extremely odd however this is fine
because i was going to be working with
mainly dynamic lighting as the scene was
extremely low poly and very performant
to work with and i wasn't making a game
i was making a cinematic so it's fine
just so you know dynamic lighting is
when all of the lights are running in
real time and baked lighting is when the
lights are baked into textures hence why
the latter is much more performant and
you should probably do that if you're
making a game or a much much bigger
project within a game engine i'll go
more into depth on the lighting in the
development part of this video once i
put these models into my level and
unreal engine i could then just move the
assets around the room where i wanted
them to be and i created a new material
for each of the objects so that i could
have it match the color palette that i
had in my documentation
including
the musician
so a very common trope of music videos
is to include the musician or musicians
in the video either playing the song and
the instruments or just being a part of
the song's narrative i knew that i also
wanted to include myself into the music
video but i wasn't quite sure how for
quite a long time i don't have the
technology or skills to
3d model myself or 3d animate
so i actually ended up recycling an idea
that i came up with in a previous short
film that i'd created in unreal engine
which is using sprite animation my idea
was to include really simple sprite
animations into the 3d bedroom to make
it appear as if ghostly versions of
myself were lingering within the room
acting out mundane movements such as
resting on my bed drinking coffee
sitting at my desk playing the guitar
this technique helped to strengthen the
overall narrative as it shows how we
spent a lot of time within the room and
also shows how the music video spans a
large length of time to create this
effect i set up the cameras in the 3d
space where i wanted each animation to
be so that i had reference for the
camera's angle and zoom and then i
recreated these as best as i could in
real life by taking videos of myself
doing the same actions in a real-life
version of the mocked up digital scene i
could then use these as a reference to
trace over in photoshop in photoshop i
imported these videos as video layers
and then scrubbed through the timeline
to find moments of that video that i
would like to trace over and then
created a new layer to trace onto by
repeating this process of tracing onto
new layers at different points of the
video i eventually saw my animation come
to life in the timeline this process
called rotoscope animation takes quite a
lot of time and patience but the outcome
is worth it and once i was happy with
the animation i then selected the layers
i had traced onto and exported them as a
sprite sheet using a photoshop script
developed by jesse freeman i'll put the
link in the description down below
having these set up as a sprite sheet
then would enable me to set them up as
sprite animations within unreal engine
4. and if you'd like a video solely
based on how i do this one effect please
give this video a thumbs up uh because i
can't go into it now we gotta move on
making it personal a music video or any
creative piece in my opinion is pretty
stale if you don't have some personality
in it that others can reflect on or
relate to for this project i was also
heavily influenced by the game life is
strange and it's moments of calm in
particular these were moments in the
game where the player could sit and
reflect on the current state of the
character within the game's story while
the camera panned around their current
surroundings highlighting items of
interest which might inform the player
more about the character or situation
they'd found themselves in throughout
this narrative and i attempted to
recreate this by adding aspects of my
own bedroom into the scene by inserting
polaroids and pictures of me of my
friends and family as well as real
entries from my journal i hope to
inspire some intrigue from the viewer
as they watched my video
and also to make the space feel alive
and lived in to do this i took well-lit
photos of the elements of my room in a
top-down view
and then removed the background in
photoshop making them pngs that could
then be used as a texture on some 3d
models such as an open book
or inside it directly onto a plain 3d
object which is basically just a flat
square in unreal engine and that's how i
created my polaroids
make use of the unreal engine
marketplace
especially when you're working as a solo
creator there's so much that goes into
making a digital video from 3d modeling
to texturing setting up the cameras
sending up the lighting and so so so
much more with this in mind i would
implore you to at least look through the
unreal engine marketplace to see if
there's anything that would help make
your workflow easier you never know when
something that you thought would take
you a long time to do or to learn it's
already available for you on the
marketplace and this will save you time
to focus on the parts of your creation
which are within your expertise for this
project i used
stylized nature packed modular building
sets and interactive stylized low poly
grass to create the outside environment
of my scene because i knew the focus
would be on the inside of the bedroom i
could kind of get away with mix mashing
multiple different low poly models from
different sets i also use good sky to
create a more stylized skyline and also
chameleon post process to handle the
visuals and the grading of the scene
post processing basically handles
everything from the color grading but
also to effect for this music video in
particular i used two post processes one
for the overall look of the scene and
then also one
where the collision bounds were just
around the window and this handled the
rain effect that you can see at the
beginning of the video i could then turn
this effect off through the sequencer so
that when the camera panned back towards
the window at the very end of the music
video there was no rain
step three developing the music video in
unreal engine 4
yes you have made it to the game dev
part
congratulations
this is where it starts to get quite
techy unreal engine offers a whole
treasure chest of goodies for you to
create your cinematics with however it
can be quite a large learning curve for
you to understand how to get the most
from it to get a more detailed insight
into how to create a cinematic please do
check out my video on how to create
cinematics in unreal engine 4. it'd be
really useful for you to watch that one
so you at least know the kind of
base principles of how to create a
cinematic within unreal engine 4 and i
don't have to then regurgitate myself
again here however with every cinematic
created i do learn something new so i
want to talk to you today about what i
learned that was new when creating this
music video here's a quick recap on some
of the terminology that i'll be using
actor an actor is any object within
unreal engine 4. material is the texture
of an actor
the way that it looks mesh is the 3d
modeled object blueprint is a visually
scripted actor that allows for bespoke
gameplay functionality variables are
properties within a blueprint that
either hold a value or reference an
actor within the world and sequencer is
the cinematic editor used within unreal
engine 4. it gives the ability to create
cinematics for the multi-track editor
and allows the user to use keyframes to
determine the content for the scene
controlling things like transformations
which moves things around
media audio and so much more
so let's take you through the things
that i learned that was new here and
that i think brought this music video to
life the first thing was lighting
this music video was set in a very small
space so lighting was extremely
important to do this i used a few
features within unreal engine that i
hadn't used previously to elevate the
lighting within my scene and allow me
more control over it number one real
time ray trace zen i got to turn that
bad boy on
now that i have a beasty pc i could use
real-time rage racing without having to
worry about whether my graphics card
could handle it if you're looking for an
easy way to get realistic lighting with
soft shadows you'll probably want to
turn this on within the render tab in
your project settings however i would
recommend
maybe duplicating your project if you're
not 100 certain that your pc graphics
card can handle it because it could just
crash your entire project and that's not
good for anyone the unreal engine
documentation states
ray tracing effects look more natural
producing soft shadowing for lights
accurate ambient occlusion ao
interactive global illumination
reflections and more
it look pretty two light ies textures my
scene had lots of small light sources
such as fairy lights and a candle
so i used ies textures to give a more
realistic lighting effects to display on
objects nearby these such as the walls
or other objects ies stands for
illuminating engineering society
profiles which are for a lighting
industry standard method of
demonstrating the brightness and
fall-off of light as it exits a
particular real-world light fixture i
used ies light profile pack which
granted me an array of textures to
choose from so i could mimic the light
fall-off of a real object because the
light is just a texture being displayed
on the objects around it it's a much
more performant way of showing realistic
lighting number three is light functions
so the ies light profile pack also came
with some light functions for me to use
these are materials that can be applied
to a light's intensity and can be used
to simulate moving events such as blinds
laser grids search lights things like
that i use this to create moving
sections of light within my mostly
static scene for example i gave the
laptop a digital glow and also on the
wall next to my bedroom window i added
strix of light moving from bottom to top
as if a car's light beams were driving
by if you'd like to know how to
manipulate these light functions then
listen to me now if not then skip to
this time stamp because
i did want to manipulate the speed and
timing of the light function i didn't
like how uniform the timing of the light
streaks were by the bedroom window and i
wanted it to appear as if cars were
driving by a bit more randomly so what i
did was i went into the light function
material duplicated it and manipulated
the material to have the textured pan
based on an artificial time which would
be fed into the material via a blueprint
at runtime in the blueprints
construction script which is used to set
up an actor on creation of the blueprint
object within the editor i made a
dynamic instance of the light function
so that i could store it as a variable
to use at runtime i then use this
reference within the blueprints event
graph which contains events and function
calls to create the artificial time
value i use a timeline which would
output an ever-changing speedfloat value
a float is a decimal formatted number
the float of speed was controlled by the
timeline's curve which would play on an
auto loop speed was then multiplied by
delta time from the on tick function
delta time is the time difference
between the previous frame that was
drawn and the current frame and on tick
runs every single frame the output of
this multiplication would update the
current value of artificial time for
that frame i then fed this artificial
time value into the light function
material so that it moved less uniformly
this blueprint held the spotlight which
would have the light function on it
talking blueprints i always just i don't
know if i'm explaining it well
finally i also learned how to manually
control the falloff of my light sources
so i could control how much light
emitted from which source it really
added to the realism of the scene
because it was lit up by multiple weak
light sources by default unreal engines
lights are set up within their details
panel to use inverse squared falloff by
unticking this option you can use
unitless intensity units and then
manipulate the light fall-off exponent
to control exactly
where the light should fall off in
distance around the light source it's a
nifty handy nifty unreal engine
documentation states inverse squared
falloff is physically based distance
fall-off where the attenuation radius is
only clamping the light's contribution
supported by all three light unit types
when disabled only unitless is available
lights with inverse squared falloff
disabled are useful when placing low
intensity fill lights where you don't
want a bright spot near the light
perfect for me so let's talk widgets and
widget animations
widgets are used to display 3d ui
elements within your scene and for this
music video i used widgets to display a
youtube page which was output through a
laptop object and also a text message
display which was output through a phone
object to do this you create a widget
blueprint to set up the ui and any
gameplay functionality for that ui
and then you can reference this within
the output actors blueprint as a widget
component the youtube page was
relatively simple with me incorporating
different sections of a real webpage
such as the tab and sidebars with a
video of the acoustic version of the
song being played
more info on how i got this video into
the widget in the next step the sidebar
incorporated images from my discord
server and also names from my patreons
who without their support i would not be
able to create things like this
i then created blueprint which stored
the laptop static mesh as well as the
widget component layered upon the screen
the phone however was a little bit more
complicated as i had to create a
blueprint which would update the most
recent text message with a string which
is just a series of characters that i
sent from the sequencer
when this happened i also set up widget
animations to create a pop-up effect
to mimic that of a real text message i
also did the same for the three dots
which represent that a person is typing
i created these animations using the
widget blueprints timeline by pressing
the plus animation button down the
bottom left and then keyframing which
element i wanted to change and where
along the allocated animation time frame
these animations then get stored as
variables within the widget blueprints
graph so that i could set up the
functions to trigger the correct
animation at the right time these got
called by the sequencer using sequencer
events more on that later
video image sequence
listen up because this totally changed
my perspective on using in engine video
so i wanted to have a video being played
as a part of the
laptop widget with the youtube page and
i wanted it to show my acoustic version
of the song refill it too as a little
easter egg to those who have watched
both versions
in the past however i have actually
struggled rendering videos through
unreal engine as a video material
because the video playback frame rate
does not stay consistent with the frame
rate of the overall video render this
makes it impossible to know which video
frame will show within the sequence
render
and also displays it at a much slower
speed than it should so this time i
decided to render a video image sequence
instead controlled by the sequencer and
this helped the problem immensely
because it's a video image sequence we
don't have to worry about the frame rate
because it's just a series
of images that it's running through very
quickly this helps extremely with the
timing it's not performant though and i
can't imagine it would be great if
you're making a video game but for a
cinematic it breaks a treat to do this i
created a jpeg sequence from my video
via vlc media player and i will leave a
detailed explanation on how to do this
in the description down below these
images will be stored within a new
folder and in unreal engine i then
created an image media source
which will store your video image
sequence and made this folder of images
the sequence path
overriding the frame rate of its output
to be 24 frames per second to match my
cinematic render this image media source
could then be used as a media track
within the sequencer so i could control
when it was playing and what frames
would play at which point i set the
track to output within the laptop widget
setting the image to be a video material
that got referenced from a media texture
which output whatever was set to play
within a media player it was here that i
set the image media source to play
and yes that was confusing setting up
videos in unreal is extremely
extremely convoluted just remember this
the image media source
is what stores my video sequence of
images
it just says this is the folder of
images
let's make a video out of it the media
player dictates what should be played
so
in my case it was my image media source
the media player
is referenced by the media texture
and then the media texture is referenced
by the media material so you can put
this video onto objects in the 3d scene
the media material is then referenced by
whatever object
is playing within the scene
in our case it was the laptop so it was
the widget i hope that makes sense and
now we had full control over which parts
of the video would be played via the
sequencer so this was so much easier
than my previous attempts at using video
in unreal engine
okay
are you still going okay good good on
you all right sequencer events
sequencer events allow you to put
triggers within the sequencer to fire
off scripted functionality within other
blueprints for example this is how we
would trigger off the animations in the
widgets that i spoke about previously
they aren't needed if you're only
wanting to change things that can
already be done within the editor such
as moving objects or turning their
visibility on off but it does really
help when you want to have more bespoke
events such as animations or spawning
actors things like that how to set these
up has been covered extensively in my
how to create a cinematic in unreal
engine 4 so i won't repeat myself here
however i will share with you something
that i think is pretty important and i
didn't mention in the previous video to
test in-game functionality that is
triggered by the sequencer events you'll
have to test the sequencer while the
game is running and to do this i go into
the level blueprint and set up a
reference to my sequencer to then play
on begin play however the game will run
when you render your final sequence so
you do not have to have this hooked up
when you render trust me this will save
you a world of time and frustration due
to crashes as you'll be forcing it to
render twice simultaneously you don't
want to do that so when you test it have
it hooked up in the level blueprint to
play the sequencer but when you render
it
unhook it
don't have that running
please and then rendering the final
video we're nearly there you nearly made
it well done well done upon rendering i
did end up taking quite a few different
takes and this is perfectly normal and i
would actually say you might want to do
this especially if you have bespoke
things such as particles or animations
as the outcome will be different each
time and it's nice to give yourself a
few different takes to choose from and
work with to speed up the export i left
the audio output format at its default
to no audio this makes sense to me as
the audio with exports as a separate
file anyway so you'd have to work in a
different software to export them
together to export your sequencer you
can do test renders first by ticking use
compression to speed up the process
adjust the compression quality to your
needs with one being the most compressed
and 100 being the best quality you can
also account for warm-up frames to start
your particle effects before your
rendering begins so that your scene
looks at its best step 4
the final step
final touches in premiere pro
using premiere pro or any other video
editing software it's a really nice way
to wrap up the video and also include
the audio this allowed me to choose the
best avi files which are the files that
unreal editor spits out after rendering
and i could use these files to clean up
any transitions and make sure that
everything cut nicely to the beat of the
song when creating the premiere pro
project i had to ensure that it was set
up to match the 24 frames per second
which the render from unreal engine was
you can do that either in the project
settings or by right clicking on an
already imported video file and choosing
modify interpret footage and change
assume this frame rate to 24 frames per
second then you export and boom
you have a little music video bubba
well done you did it
now you can release
wasn't that simple
okay maybe not simple but hey it's
attainable
game ninjas are free did you know that
so there you have it a music video
created entirely from scratch and from
home all within
a game engine
and
a little bit of help from a video
editing software
i know i've bombarded you with a lot of
information so i really commend you for
sticking with me in this video
ultimately the more you use any software
and this also goes for game engines the
more you will understand the best way to
use it and what works for you and the
projects that you would like to create
within it and all i can do and all i do
try to do is share with you my findings
whenever i use it to create my
projects i hope this was somewhat
insightful and educational i just really
wanted to
be put out there that making a music
video really is something that that is
attainable that can be done within a
games engine if you choose to
and i i would like to help others do the
same and realize the same i also realize
that there is a lot of information to to
try to condense down into one video like
this one if i raise any points that you
would like to hear more of in detail
then please do let me know in the
comments down below and perhaps i'll
look into doing shorter videos that go
into more depth on certain aspects
either way i wish you the very best in
all of your creative endeavors and if
you do decide to use unreal engine or
any game engine unity as well is a great
one
to create videos music videos
anything then let me know i'd really
like to see what you do with it as
always if you'd like to see more videos
like this one please do
subscribe
click the thumbs up do the bell and all
that kind of stuff i'd really appreciate
it and if you want to see more of this
face then i stream every thursday at 8
30 p.m gmt over on twitch description
down below for all of my socials and all
that jazz um but yeah i think that's
probably enough of me rambling now thank
you so much for sticking with me really
appreciate it i don't know how long this
video is going to be but
oh i feel like i've been sitting here
for only 30 days i've also written an
article format of this video so if you
want to
read that and
soak up more information then you can
check it out on my medium which is also
down in the description down below
really hope that i did an alright job of
explaining some of these things because
i try and make these videos as
accessible as possible but
you know there's only so much you can do
in in one video isn't there but i also
don't want to
not give you enough information so it's
a tough one
it's a tough one have a lovely day or
evening bye
i am so yellow this top is like
reflecting on my face
[Music]
a world so
quiet now
so quiet now
[Music]
you